[Music]
you would munching oh my god I'm so
sorry I will leave
sit back down
what's your name again
Jake cake um you want to sit at the big
table don't you cake more than I've ever
wanted anything let me ask you a
question do you think Santa Claus is
heavy I'm pretty Jewish so I don't think
said is heavy maybe started out heavy he
wanted to bring joy to the world so we
created Christmas but after he was done
enough chimneys he found out that
everyone likes Christmas
but some people are Jewish or Democrats
who they think Christmas shouldn't be
about gifts
so now sadder lives all alone at the
North Pole
surrounded by elves and reindeer under
pains and doesn't trust he can't tell
anymore of Christmases good or bad
trust me Santa Claus isn't happy
you're better off being a dirty
elf is that carrier or innocent
yes I love kids me too now I'd like you
to leave
Jesus sorry I got a bit of an
emotional day oh well I understand hey
what have you got there oh well there's
one person in this office what a worse
day than me and I thought this would
cheer him up you mean me
[Music]
I'll guitar well I don't play Oh
why would you do such a nice thing for
me because it's remembered a thank you
bet
[Music]